everybody happy friday we have a
kova 19 briefing with dr teresa tam and
dr howard new joining us virtually we'll
begin with opening remarks and then turn
to
the room and phone lines for questions
with a heart out at 12 30. so over to
you doctors
thank you very much and bonjour
last week's modeling update illustrated
how the large surge you know with crime
infections was likely to peak in january
and then recede into february
in the weeks since the modeling update
there are early indications that
infections may have peaked at the
national level including daily case
counts test positivity
rt or the effective reproduction number
and wastewater surveillance trends
however daily hospital and icu numbers
are still rising steeply and many
hospitals across canada are under
intense strain
nationally the average daily case count
has decreased by 28
compared to the previous week
although there is a degree of
underestimation due to current testing
policies the seven day average of close
to 27 000 cases reported daily as of
january 19 shows continuing high rates
of infection
as well with over 22 percent of lab
tests positive for the covet 19 virus
disease activity remains widespread
across the country
modeling also showed us that the high
volume of co omicron cases was expected
to result in an unprecedented number of
new daily hospital admissions exceeding
historical maximums
over the past week an average of over 10
000 people with covert 19 were being
treated in our hospitals each day
surpassing peak daily numbers for all
previous waves of the pandemic
this includes over 1 100 people in
intensive care units which is higher
than or but the third wave peak
during the same period there were on
average 131 deaths reported each day
evidence continues to show that being
vaccinated with two or more doses of
covert 19 vaccines lowers the risk of
hospital emission
as well having a booster dose of either
fisa biontec or moderna mrna covert 19
vaccine helps improve protection that
may have decreased since the second
those and results in a better protection
against severe illness from omicron in
particular
with over 6.5 million eligible canadians
needing a first or second dose of the
primary series and many others who are
eligible for a booster dose there are
still more opportunities to enhance our
protection individually and collectively
with covert 19 vaccines
among adolescent and adult age groups
vaccine coverage with two or more doses
range from 83 percent to 96
with room for improvement particularly
on boosted dose coverage for adults
which ranges from 21 to 75 percent
for children aged 5 to 11 years who more
recently became eligible for covet 19
vaccination the key opportunity in
getting more children on the path to
vaccine protection by starting their
primary series and raising vaccine
coverage up from the present 51
with at least one dose
one of the ways we work to build
confidence among this age group is
through the immunization partnership
fund or ipf
the ipf supports trusted organizations
across canada to share credible
timely covet 19 vaccination information
with their communities
these organizations can help reach
underserved and under vaccinated
populations with tailored outreach and
interventions to fill information gaps
and reduce vaccination barriers
next thursday a number of organizations
including ipf funded recipients
children's healthcare canada and signs
up first as well as experts from across
disciplines will be coming together to
promote vaccine confidence and highlight
the importance of building up protection
among children during national kids and
vaccines day
i encourage parents and guardians
together with their children to take the
opportunity to engage with experts and
advocates that respect and support the
need for informed and confident decision
making
but we still have some difficult weeks
ahead and potential for more bumps along
the way
our many months of efforts have given us
better protection with vaccines and
brought us several effective treatments
that we remain hopeful will change the
face of the pandemic to reduce severity
going forward
we can all help to ease the path to
better days ahead by getting our covert
19 vaccines up to date and continuing to
reduce infection rates by laying
layering personal protections such as
masking and limiting in-person contacts
as much as possible
thank you merci meiguich
bonjour
hospital
foreign
thank you
okay thank you so much doctors we have
quite a bit of time for questions today
but given that we had very few people
able to get through on the phone lines
on monday i'll ask for questions to be
brief and answers as well to be brief if
possible we'll start in the room with
mackenzie gray and then go to the phone
lines
uh hi dr tam my first question is about
a study that came out with the cdc today
there's some really strong numbers about
boosters 90 effective against
hospitalizations 82 effective against
preventing people ending up in the
hospital
and people with a booster are 66 percent
less effective to end up getting an
infection against omicron versus people
who only have two shots the top cdc
advisors already come out today after
this and said look we need to change the
definition of what it means to be fully
vaccinated to be three shots so now is
it only a matter of time in canada that
three shots is going to be the standard
for fully vaccinated versus two shots
and i i think um
it's very important to get the booster
so that is the first
message as i've said in my opening
remarks so everyone
should try and get the boosters as soon
as they're eligible
and that's a that's really important i
think um it depends on the objective of
um what the definitions are used for
um and a lot of it in in the
jurisdiction of the provinces and
territories but we will be discussing
this going forwards as i said once
there's been more people who
having had the opportunity to access the
boosted doses
on kids you mentioned dr knew maybe i
could just add to that
i think there's sometimes maybe a bit of
confusion i think in the general public
as to you know what is a booster dose
and so i think uh what uh dr tam and i
are sometimes used a phraseology is
better sort of keeping up to date with
your vaccinations because uh let's say
for the large part of the population uh
maybe getting two doses you know maybe
eight weeks apart and so might
constitute what we call a primary series
you get a good level of immunity from
from that but for others who may not be
able to mountain a good immune response
maybe code their primary series might
actually consist of three doses as a you
know as opposed to the two doses so and
then after that you know if you have a
good response from your primary series
then quote a booster dose is the one
that you might be giving you know six
months or later after that sort of uh
completion of your primary series to
then bring your immunity up after it
wanes over time so you're right there's
still lots to uh to look at and and
nasty will be looking at sort of the
overall question of booster doses and
timing but i just wanna maybe clarify
that issue in terms of what constitutes
the number of doses in the primary
series versus booster
thanks
on kids dr tim you mentioned your
remarks that only 51 of eligible kids
are fully vaccinated this point in time
which means that there are a lot of
parents out there who are fully
vaccinated themselves but have decided
not to make sure that their kids get
vaccinated why do you think there's such
a disconnect potentially with hundreds
of thousands or millions of fully
vaccinated parents
not letting their kids or not wanting
their kids to end up getting vaccinated
because i think we need
to
look at
the
reasons behind this more closely but
what i do know is before the program
started
that there was a very high proportion of
early adopters around 50
so maybe that's what we're seeing but
there were quite a high proportion 25 to
30 percent i believe i can't quite
recall the exact uh
public opinion research numbers but
around that sort of ballpark of parents
who are just waiting and seeing because
of course children are very important in
their lives and their primary
piece of information they wanted to know
is are the vaccines safe
and so i think i could we can now safely
say that millions of doses of this
suffice the
lower those vaccinations for children
have been deployed there's no safety
signals
of concern and so i think it's this
group of parents that we're hoping to
reach in so many different ways
as i've said with the immunization
partnership fund to make sure parents
and kids uh get their questions answered
so i think this is the next phase to try
and get uh that next group of uh kids
vaccinated
and
some of our experts will be providing
their time next week to answer those
questions so
both access to information and access
easy access to the vaccine i think is
very key for the next phase
okay patrick will go to you on the phone
lines
you merci you may press star one at this
time if you have a question
for
me
systems
[Music]
foreign
and we leave the deciders we leave it up
to decision making thank you merci the
next question is from david aiken from
global news please go ahead
well thank you very much uh doctors
appreciate your time um maybe dr tam
this is for you it sort of goes to that
that fund
announcement today about disinformation
we have some new polling that suggests
canadians do have some concerns about
getting ever more covet 19 shots
boosters and i know doctor knew you were
saying you know it's important to keep
up to date on vaccines but a lot of
canadians when asked you know would you
get a fourth dose they sort of roll
their eyes ago they seem to be resistant
so i'm wondering if you have some
thoughts about how our vaccine strategy
might change the communications
uh is it likely we'll need annual
boosters um strain specific vaccines
vaccines for the most vulnerable only i
wonder if you could speak about the
vaccine strategy in a climate where
people are wondering oh i got to get a
fourth dose or or more doses
yes i think we have to examine of course
the data
and in numerous streams including the
level of protection the vaccine
effectiveness studies
i think we were very fortunate to get
some very effective vaccines quite early
on in the pandemic and we are
essentially learning about some of the
spacing in the doses and the number of
is required but at the same time as
studying that the virus itself is also
undergoing evolution so there's another
stream of data that we need to watch out
for
but what i will say is that i i think
the global opinion at this point is that
the omicron virus is going to be with us
for some time so we do need to take a
longer term approach in thinking about
our vaccine strategy so i think that
that's the next step and we need to do
that with the national advisory
committee on immunization of course
they've been
asked to examine the need for example of
a fourth dose
but they are taking very thoughtful
approaches to examine that question
um but
i think everybody would appreciate that
for influenza for example that's um now
an annual vaccine people had that i've
had that for decades you know every year
so it's not a question of whether
know many different doses in our
lifetimes is a concern i think we have
very good examples of where vaccines can
be given um time and again over the
course of our lives
but it is
i think quite an important moment and
then the next year leading up to the
next uh respiratory virus season to try
and work this out as much as possible so
there are a number of unknowns as you've
pointed out in terms of
well what
strain should we be using um and
who needs to get an additional dose i do
think that the primary objectives
have to be clarified and right now i
think the key is to prevent serious
outcomes and we need to look at that
going forward as well
and uh just a data follow-up really this
may be available at somebody's dashboard
i just haven't seen it um
dr jam you talked about um the number of
people in hospitals the number of people
in icu's um with kovid do we
have a rough idea of how many of those
in hospitals or in icus
are dealing with omicron or delta or
even the alpha variant do we know
uh or to have some data some perspective
on which particular variant is pushing
up these hospital case hospital counts
yes not everyone in the hospital will
have genetic sequences done some will
get
targeted genetic uh screening to look at
uh what we call an s gene dropout so you
will not get that precisely from every
uh hospitalized patient but what we do
know is from our surveillance system
that is almost all omicron
ever since around december the 20th
as omicron began to really take over the
majority of the genetic landscape as it
were uh that's what we expect to be in
the hospitals right now we're not seeing
much in the way of delta or any other
variant but we're monitoring that very
closely and by the way including the sub
lineages of omicron which is getting a
bit of news today i think
thank you mercilessly
[Music]
give recommendations
foreign
thank you merci
the next question is from mia robson
from the canadian press please go ahead
hi good morning um i'm curious if you
could talk a little bit about the death
rates that we're seeing and the death
numbers we're seeing from covid in this
particular month uh the numbers seem to
have climbed substantially including
among children and i'm just wondering if
that's severity related or if this is
still because there's just so many
people getting omicron
yes i think there's
there's a street to term i'll answer
your question first
i think it is the sheer volume of
cases
and at the beginning of
the omicron wave
it was very much concentrated on younger
adults
and then they began to spread into the
other age groups as one might expect
so i think the vast majority of the
severe outcomes though are still in the
elderly population people who are over
the age of 60 uh the key
population groups ending up with the
more severe outcomes in the hospitals
and the mortality uh is the highest in
the very uh
oldest age groups so so that is still
the trend that we're seeing uh there may
be some reports of severe outcomes in
children but they're still very rare in
terms of rates they're still very low
thank you and earlier this week you were
at the health committee and you were
asked a few times about the quarantine
period the isolations that have been
lowered in most provinces now um i'm
wondering if you could say what advice
the public health agency is giving
provinces about easing these isolation
dates from ten to seven to five days etc
and what role testing should play in the
decision about whether or not someone
should come out of isolation
yes at the special advisory committee we
share information and the
synthesis of the evidence that we have
gathered on an ongoing basis with the
province and territories
in terms of the isolation period for
example there was very little
information as you can imagine coming
out at the beginning of the omicron wave
and then there were a few studies that
were being published which suggested
that
the periods
during which you can shed the virus
and can potentially communicate is not
that different from
other variants having said that there's
a
massive number of cases
and this has a great impact on our
society on our critical services on the
health care service itself
so provinces uh recognizing
the data that we have
made the decisions from a policy
perspective and a business business
continuity perspective for example to
address some of the policies but all of
them have said that regardless whether
it's five days or seven days for the
rest of that period you have to wear a
well-fitted high-quality mask and take
on those other layers of protection
because there's always a possibility
that transmission could occur so so
those are ongoing uh discussions for
sure and the same with the quarantine
period in terms of well exactly what is
the incubation period what is the latent
period so we have those technical
discussions but in the end uh provinces
have the tough job of making it work on
the ground and
i think that's the situation that we're
in now
thank you merci
discussion
and the same with the quarantine period
in terms of well exactly
i'm sorry uh madame
whoever is playing audio of dr tim on
the line could stop discussion
and the same with the foreign period
i'll have to go with the next question
uh the next question is from david
thurton from cbc news please go ahead
hi yes um this question's for dr tam is
she the same person
of
the institute of health metrics and
evaluation out of the university of
washington has said today that the
pandemic is winding down the pandemic is
winding down and will be over by april
with covet essentially becoming a
seasonal flu so dr cam your thoughts on
this please
i think
that
there are many experts in the world
trying to work out this question and i
don't think the um
what you just said was
you know it's necessarily b
uh
scenario but it is a possible scenario
so i think we need to prepare for
different
potential
futures
i think one other scenario is that of
course after this massive omicron wave
and we have boosters
and more kids are getting vaccinated
the population should have a reasonably
good immunity at least for this period
of time and at least against the omicron
variant
so we need to see how that immunity
continues
we know that waning immunity does occur
and we need to prepare for any potential
unusual variants that might come along
at the same time though we do need to
lay out a strategy and a plan towards
moving back to something that is nearer
normality
and i think one thing that many experts
do agree on is
the
omicron um well not the omicron the
quran the covert 19
is going to stay
and the corona virus will continue
to be in the human population so how do
we manage that going forwards i think
it's quite reasonable to think that we
need to plan for the next respiratory
virus season as well
thank you for that the same institute
also suggests that omicron the omicron
wave will essentially be over in a few
weeks and that it will be time to lift
mass mandates vaccine passports and
other restrictions
so yeah your thoughts on that as well dr
tan
i think we gave some idea at the
national level as to where this wave is
going so
i think
in the january time frame
the peak may occur
but the hospitalizations and the ico
emissions may continue to increase for
some time so that's in february
and i really hope that
by the end of that next month we'll be
in a better position
and during that time
people are very busy of course
responding to the omicron wave but we
need to plan ahead for the next phase
and
that
you know we have to focus on our goals
which i i think has been articulated as
reducing severe illness
and
severe mobility and mortality as well as
reducing societal disruptions so that
balance has to be
worked out
there is no doubt that nobody wants to
have all these restrictive measures
anymore and omicron may or may not have
put us one step towards that newer
reality
so i think as i said we need to plan for
the different scenarios and just be
ready for a time of emergence of of new
variants but we got to move on and see
how we can
make our societal functions
closer to what they were before the
pandemic
it's dr new maybe i can uh just comment
further you're mentioning two tools and
sort of the word mandates attached to
that i think you know the way i look at
it you were talking about vaccines and
masks i think you know from a public
health perspective we want people to be
sort of informed and make that a
voluntary choice you know to
get a vaccine because we know that
vaccines are a very important tool safe
and effective in terms of how we manage
uh not just the omicron variant to wave
right now but just for covert 19 into
the future so i think that's something a
positive we need to keep building on and
as as far as the use of mask as you put
it i think it's it's i think in many
ways an empowering sort of personal
protective measure that people should be
encouraged it doesn't have to be because
there's a mandate it's because people
see the value in and of itself to
protect themselves and protect others to
uh wear a wearer mask and maybe even in
the future it's not because of a cover
19 but also maybe for other respiratory
viruses maybe they'll get baked in as
they say in terms of a sort of a good
personal protective habit that
will always you know maintain you know
through let's say winter and respiratory
uh virus season so so that's how i would
look at it in terms of
looking at the sort of the negative ways
for goal we can lift mandates on masks
etc thank you
[Music]
[Music]
um
um
uh
thank you merci the next question is
from ryza patel from the toronto star
please go ahead
thanks for taking our questions dr tam
back in december you published an annual
report in which you said canada was not
prepared to handle a crisis of the
magnitude of kobit 19. at the time you
said it was too early to know how
omicron would impact our pandemic
response but now that we have a better
understanding of omicron do you think
this country was not prepared to handle
that variant as well
i think
this pandemic has affected every country
in the world and canada is not
any different but to sustain this
response for this long is also a massive
challenge
and i think based on the last set of
questions as well that
it's really difficult to
maintain the health system as a whole
um
functioning for this long with this much
pressure
so i think a lot of our pandemic
response to the omicron
way for this current wave that we're in
much of it is to protect
that health system particularly the
healthcare system
from
being
you know really under pressure so i
think canadians understand that that's
partly why
you know on the ground some of the
measures had to be enacted because
we can't you can't cope with this level
of icu emissions
and hospitalization without some
major
uh impacts and what is different about
this wave compared to others is the
absenteeism and because of of the
infection rates and the high
transmissibility of the omicron wave so
it is quite a challenging wave which is
different from other waves is the
continuity of the health human resource
and so i think
those challenges continue and
but of course we're not
alone in that and
but
again only together and and by
supporting our health systems can we get
through this
and as a follow-up ben do you think that
the federal government should have done
more since the onset of the pandemic to
help provinces and territories expand
testing capacity and healthcare capacity
to prepare for surges like the one we're
seeing now
well i think um
you know
every everything is being done to try
and support
those things as i understand it
you can you can try and
buy up as many tests as possible et
cetera but there's deployment on the
ground
um that
needs to be done and some of it is uh
some of the testing limitations is not
because
you don't have enough pcr testing uh lab
infrastructure is because some of the
people were sick and some of the people
who collect
samples were sick
so it's a very different scenario
to be working with but i think getting
enough vaccines making sure there's
boosters
continuing to supply
the testing support as as
fast as much as we can
those are some of the fundamentals and
of course evolving our guidance to make
sure canadians can protect themselves as
much as possible
in a pandemic scenario for example for
influenza
where we did envisage scenarios where
everybody has a synchronous wave more or
less and you're all impacted
and the ability to provide surge and
help each other in mutual aid is
very difficult to sustain under those
circumstances and so
pandemic plans always
have to deal with prioritization and
those difficult decisions that have to
be made so i think
i believe everyone is doing the best
that they can
but i think
ahead of next winter again we need to
plan ahead and see what we can do to
make sure the systems are as sustainable
as they can but
i think everybody that i've talked to
have said is the exhaustion of the
health human resource and
um
and the sickness
moderator how many more questions do we
have on the phone line
we have at this time two questions left
okay great if we could um get both in
that would be fantastic
um
[Music]
um
um
[Music]
foreign
measures thank you merci you may still
press star one if you have a question
the next question is from christine
barak from cbc national news please go
ahead
uh thank you both for taking our
questions mine is on the rapid test
front
based on a research project uh nova
scotia health is now recommending people
swap both their nose and throat to get
more accurate rapid test results just
wanted to get your sense of that
approach and the latest data on this you
know people are to some degree relying
on these tests what should they be
keeping in mind
yes thank you for the question that's a
great uh canadian study so
we really welcome that we actually had
dr hatchett present to the chief of
medical officers
uh very recently on his uh results so we
will be taking that into account and
i've asked
our laboratory networks our laboratory
experts to take that into account and
see whether we can provide some further
guidance but
of course
i think we
have been discovering that the omicron
virus may be behaving a bit differently
to the previous variants
and so this uh approach to swabbing
might be useful but uh different kits
have different swabs and i learned a lot
about that sort of recently some of them
are more flexible some of them are
designed a bit differently so i think i
think the different kits need to be
examined but i think uh his study
uh will go uh
it's very welcome and we'll go go a long
way in terms of helping us with our next
set of recommendations that's not to say
that well what about the next variant
you know so so i think it's it's really
great that these studies are being done
and
uh i look forward to our lab network
maybe uh providing the next set of
guidance that canadians need
what would be your um that's great i'm
glad that you're briefed on the research
project but what would be based on what
you've seen and i guess the amount of
research you have done on your own
recently what's your best advice at this
point for for using rapid tests
i think dr hatchetts and his team's
results
is looking at how you swab and
in this current context uh using the
kits that he's examined
uh swabbing the back of your throat and
then the
nose area
is
potentially provide you with the highest
yields but if you can only do one site
go along with the manufacturer's
instructions and do the nasal
swabs so i think that's
uh
looks like some very sensible advice
because rapid tests
um we've got to make the best use of
them so if by
some adjustments to the swabbing
technique we can get a high yield that's
always a great thing to do
operator are there any other questions
on the phone line if not we have one
more in the room
the owner for the questions on the phone
okay excellent i will take this
opportunity to ask dr tam a follow-up
from ctv's question for my colleagues in
toronto
you said that there is a question of
definition
regarding boosters and whether that's
part of being fully vaccinated can you
please explain what that question is are
you questioning whether we need booster
as part of the definition for fully
vaccinated
um that might is that referring to an
earlier question um i think
yeah it's referring
to mckenzie gray
okay so
currently
for a number of administrative purposes
and in the on the ground in the province
and territories for um
going into a certain setting for example
there is a definition for for what fully
vaccinated is
which consists of really the primary
series so a two dose vaccine you need
two doses one those vaccine the jensen
vaccine is that first dose but we all
know that it is very important to get
the boosted dose particularly in the
time of omicron so we began to switch
terminologies now to the concept of
being up to date so by being up today is
if you are in certain group age groups
and you're eligible for the booster
getting the booster or the additional
dose is what we mean by up to date but
that has not been built into the
definition
for uh a ministry of purposes of whether
you can enter a certain space or going
to a certain task or indeed for
international travel that has not
changed it's still the primary series or
the first two doses for the most part
and but we will be examining
re-examining those kind of policies
going forwards particularly uh now's not
the right time because not everybody's
had the chance to get that additional
dose or getting up to date
not in canada and certainly not globally
so we will need to re-examine that
posture in the future
thank you and just going to mia's
question on the increasing death rates
regarding quebec is quebec a leading
indicator of what we will see in death
rates across canada or is there
something different in the experience of
hospital healthcare system in quebec
that is leading to higher death rates in
quebec than elsewhere
i think
quebec is certainly one of the provinces
that experienced the omicron surge the
earliest so that could play into it but
there may be other factors as well
whether it's related to the
the actual
impact of the omegon wave in
the quebec population
but i think there were some questions
about uh differences in methodology and
reporting of the deaths
so maybe a number of these factors are
playing into the
different
numbers but all to say though is
omicron can cause serious outcomes we
cannot trivialize this virus
many people who are particularly those
at high risk
can get very severely sick and indeed
many have died and we need to do what we
can to prevent those
okay that wraps up all our questions for
today thank you both to dr tam and dr
new for being so generous with your time
have a good rest of the day and happy
weekend
you too thank you thank you bye-bye